well a bar in Portland Oregon offered a
reparations happy hour earlier this week
in which white people were not invited
to attend but were invited to pay for
about a hundred people did pay their
racial indulgences that provided enough
cash to cover free drinks for the
non-white people who showed up what is
this about exactly well Cameron Witten
is the activist who organized it and he
joins us sign it Cameron how you doing
hey Tucker it's good to see you again
nice to see you so what's that what's
the thinking here so reparations happy
hour is a event about a successful event
that was put on by nonprofit Brown hope
you find more information out on brown
hope org and what we did was that forty
black brown and it dishes people
attended this event we had over a
hundred and fifty white people donate
and this wasn't about alcohol I've been
sober for twenty seven years so you can
trust that I was not putting on an
alcoholic event when we did was we built
community and we made a space to heal
from the impacts of racism and I believe
that you as a conservative can respect
the fact that we had people voluntarily
support this event and show that we as
individuals can take action to heal from
the impacts of racism it's a little
patronizing no though I mean because the
because the assumption is that all black
people are poor and need the help of
white people and it makes the white
people feel virtuous like they're coming
to the rescue and I don't know how it
makes a black people feel better
probably makes some of them feel
patronized
I would think Thank You Tucker so I saw
your show I saw your segment about
racism Roseanne Barr
we're both beuter agree that racism is
real we both agree that racism goes two
ways yeah we're saying is that racial
disparities if you look at our country
the color of your skin is a predictor of
how long you'll live what kind of
economic level you'll be in and other
factors and so we're saying is that
actually run is someone who's familiar
with the numbers let me just say it's
not quite that simple I mean that
broadly maybe but I mean African
immigrants to this country have higher
income levels than native-born white
Americans so it's not quite as not white
and white as you're suggesting so and I
guess that's kind of the point that I am
making is that not all black people are
the same not all white people are the
same you have different attitudes
different income levels and this
kind of suggests they are because you're
saying if you're a certain color you're
in one category if you're in a another
color you're not another category that
makes me uncomfortable what we're saying
that racism is real and that racial
disparities exist and so we're offering
a solution saying that we are calling on
folks from a privileged demographic to
pay into a solution and invest in the
leadership of black brown and digis
people by Peggy no carbon exceptions we
appear about the facts and the first
state that racial disparities exist and
brown hope has offered solutions for us
to build syntax of racism I think it's a
very clever deal you got going pay for
my drinks and everything like that thank
you you are an entrepreneur in a
hilarious way but let me ask this would
it make you feel have thought that a
tiny event that Ernie happened in
Portland and now am on Fox News now New
York this is a clever event we elevated
reparation but let me ask you what it
make you uncomfortable if someone who
made less than you did paid for your
meal or your drinks because you were a
different color would that make you feel
uncomfortable so what we're looking at
is the real wealth disparity in our
country and we know that the wealth
disparity between blacks and whites is
between is around 10 to 1 so we know
that the spirit is just speaking in
general contract well I already gave you
one of my counter facts was African
immigrants make more than white
Americans on average talking about the
realities of this country sticks
no no what an oaf a believable I I'm
amused but let me ask you this you -
does it make you uncomfortable to
generalize on the basis of race in the
way that you are despite the fact you're
making money from it which again as a
capitalist I applaud I mean it's a it's
an amazing scam but yes no so believe in
looking at the civil rights movement we
saw that racial disparities existed
and you can be like Oh generally some
people will celebrates era where doctors
are some people who could vote so we've
always had exceptionalism but in the
general fact look at the facts the facts
matter and we know that racial we're
living with our partners to invest in
this works we were successful more
successful shénme of guilt offering my
drinks yeah you you are winning this
game you are the winner I love that
camera and I can tell you the majority
of people who came to we got ten dollars
in cash in the money on gas gave it to
friends paid for it this is not about
alcohol
we raised a great issue we called it
happy hours show you money
this event was about you made money
that's right we elevated reparations
elevated Christian says good job are you
unfortunately time you're a capitalist I
know that I thought I was a capitalist
talking about you